what's going on guys this is rob and i
am back from my vacation yes i
absolutely loved that cruise fyi i will
be at san diego comic-con so i don't
know how many of you guys are going to
be there maybe i'll do a fan meet-up
i'll probably announce it here in the
next week or so we'll try to find a
better place to do it than we did last
time
because i didn't realize i had never
been to san diego before i didn't
realize how much of a mad house it was
although i guess i probably should have
known but we are back on our regular
schedule which means we are covering
infinite frontier and as you guys know
infinite frontier is this next great big
huge multiversal event so in the
playlist for infinite frontier we did
put in there um the story of kingdom
come because that was kind of a
necessity now there is and this is
something that we'll cover later on
we'll actually do thy kingdom come uh
and also the kingdom as well which is
the kingdom come slash jsa crossover
which is actually what the earth 22
universe here in uh in dark crisis is
more based off of but to understand that
you have to understand kingdom come so
that's the reason why we covered it but
um what we know right now kind of
continuing things up from where we were
before that you've got alan scott and
then you have a son obsidian and they're
basically looking for allen's daughter
obsidian sister though the superhero
known as jade and the reason why is
because the jsa headquarters in gotham
had basically exploded there was an
indication that jade's power had been
there and so the question became what
happened to her and they're quite
literally on the trail trying to figure
out who it was that had done this and
that had presumably taken out jade and
so of course their trail ultimately ends
up leading them to a guy by the name of
shade now people who are long time
readers of dc comics what i mean long
time i mean since zero hour crisis in
time they are aware of the character of
roger swift the reality here is he's
been around for much longer than that
but like so many characters from dc
comics he's received uh you know reboots
new origins all that kind of stuff with
each passing crisis way back in the day
in the 1940s in the old all-star comics
he was originally part of the injustice
society and the way the injustice
society originally existed back then is
they were essentially the opposite or
the antithesis of the the justice
society itself that where the various
superheroes came together to form the
jsa as it existed the injustice society
of america was basically their villains
forming a team it just made logical
sense given the way that comics were
written at the time and it was really
popular i will say that i think the
popularity of shade really reached its
peak almost immediately after zero hour
and then just kind of started tapering
off after that to the point that now
he's one of these characters you see
every once in a while and unless you're
like a really hardcore fan you're
probably not going to know or care who
this guy is but the ones that do love
this guy love to see him appear i don't
have no idea how many people are fans of
shade
but the reality is this guy is by all
standards of measurement he has the
ability to manipulate what's in effect
dark force energy shadow energy those
guys coming from marvel comics you know
the dark forces being able to manipulate
like literal shadows the living abyss of
null different things like that right
just the nature of shadows themselves
that's effectively what shade does again
he's been around long before that so
it's not really one of these instances
where dc copied marvel or you know those
of you guys who are looking to create
those arguments that don't matter but
the thing about this is that this guy
has been around the block more than a
few times and that's why their trail
leads and leaves them to him because
this guy has kind of been around the
various villains that exist out there so
even if he's not the one responsible for
the vanishing of shade at the very least
he may have information leading to that
now one of the things to remember is
that the role of alan scott and obsidian
in them is only one part of this story
that what we end up doing is basically
switching back to roy harper now one of
the big focal points here is that roy
harper is simply just back and we don't
really know how he came back we
certainly just know that he's here and
he's in possession of a black lantern
and that's one of the things that blew
me away and a lot of people who are
familiar with dc comics surprised them
as well because whenever a person is
brought back to life by a black lantern
ring they're usually under the direct
control of a black lantern ring right
like it literally dominates their will
and they basically come back as zombies
with roy harper it wasn't that way roy
harper came back as we'd always seen him
and not only that he was in control of
the black lantern ring which is not how
that's supposed to work so it's one of
those things where whatever is going on
with him and this ring is pretty far
removed from the standard quo of black
lanterns so that's really kind of the
question and one of the reasons why you
saw a lot of people in the comments who
were like okay what's going on with roy
harper now of course he's also looking
for his daughter kind of hunting around
but the thing about this is that
whenever he utilizes the ring he falls
under its control so it's not as though
this ring is not a black lantern ring it
is it's just the relationship between
roy and the ring is different from what
we're normally used to seeing and so
that's why when he suddenly ends up you
know when he used the ring at the end of
the the last story and then suddenly
just flew into space that once he
regains his bearings in a lot of ways
trying to find his daughter is what kind
of anchors him back to reality that he's
able to sort of retake control over the
ring but not necessarily use it in the
sense of like conjuring constructs and
different things like that and that's
the sort of of quagmire that he's in is
on one hand he wants to use the ring but
on the other hand he doesn't want to
turn into like some kind of a black
lantern zombie but in the midst of all
this he's suddenly met by the arrival of
someone now again at that point we
switch over to earth 22 what is
essentially the kingdom come universe
just kind of a little modified and again
that'll make more sense once we cover
the kingdom and thy kingdom come the the
kingdom come and jsa crossover once we
cover that this will also make a lot
more sense as well but magog of course
is a reformed guy and that's why you
have calvin ellis right the the superman
of the justice incarnate you've also got
thomas wayne flashpoint batman who were
here and they're a little surprised by
this guy now again when you see maggot
talking and basically having this
understanding of the multiverse that all
came from thy kingdom come that was the
significance of that story because you
literally had uh like what is a kingdom
come superman who basically transitioned
to the justice society of america which
is a pretty cool story it was a pretty
cool set of events but that's why he has
this recognition because if you guys
recall our coverage of the kingdom come
story he didn't know anything about the
multiverse and there's nothing to
indicate any of the heroes know anything
about the multiverse the story was
originally self-contained it wasn't
designed to tie into anything it was
just it was really an elseworld story
without the else world's title and it
was just in some alternate reality out
there somewhere things popped off and a
superhero civil war happened the end and
like that was it
that was literally the whole thing here
so that's why when you see magog here
he's not a tried and true villain he
doesn't attack them because he's like
good guys i gotta kill you it's not
really anything like that it's more of
every time the multiverse shows up here
there's problems right there's issues
that unfold now there is a little more
that goes on with this character and of
course we'll learn about that once we
get to the end of this but the thing
about it is of course the justice
incarnate shows up here right so you got
like machine head you got captain carrot
i love captain carrot captain carrots
super bunny you got him you got mary
marvel you got aqua woman you got all
those characters that show up here but
that's where things are kind of halted
by calvin because from their perspective
it's a fight breaking out here between a
villain and a hero or a villain that was
supposed to have been redeemed and
basically ended up going back to being a
bad guy when the response of calvin is
no no he says the reason why we're here
is because the ship that thomas wayne
had escaped from pieces of it are all
over the place and we're trying to
figure out what's going on with this
ship who made it all that stuff because
we have no clue what's happening here
right it's this great big huge
multiversal puzzle and they only have
one piece of it and they don't fully
understand everything that's taking
place but remember when it comes to the
multiverse and dc comics it's all about
harmonic frequencies remember every
universe vibrates with a particular
frequency so for the sake of of
discussion here right using arbitrary
frequencies here we could say that uh
the main dc universe earth 0 vibrates in
the key of a and the an earth 1 vibrates
in the key of a sharp and earth 2 is in
b and or 3's and b sharp and so on and
so forth the reason why this matters is
because if you are a group like the
justice incarnate or you're familiar
with the multiverse somebody like the
flash you could have a superhero who
could just show up batman could show up
here and just say hey what's going on
barry but barry could detect his
harmonic frequency and realize you're
vibrating in the key of b you are not
from this universe you are from a
different universe and so he would know
he's not native to that place and then
start asking questions like why are you
here how did you get here so on and so
forth but it's why calvin ellis can
touch this ship and realize it comes
from a different reality so that's why
they end up traveling back to earth 23
to his reality to kind of continue the
hunt on where this ship came from and so
at that point you switch over to barry
allen and he's kind of been the
character that's been missing here for a
little while right the efforts of barry
and his journey to kind of explore the
multiverse or see what's going on with
the multiverse different things like
that ultimately led him to a particular
location right known as earth omega we
don't know the significance of it
outside of the fact that it seems to be
the end of the multiverse but the only
thing we knew is that he's basically
here or at least seemingly being
manipulated by the psycho pirate now one
of the cool things and one of the things
i love the most about this is that
joshua williamson and dc are going to
give us the full-on explanation of
psychopirate in terms of how he exists
now a little bit of a spoiler although
we will cover it later on is it psycho
pirate is the only or really one of the
only characters that exists now in the
dc landscape who is aware of his history
before the events of the first crisis on
infinite earth and that's how he always
was that was always the nature of
psychopirate and it's why he always
maintained just kind of this this sort
of interesting element about him and why
a lot of fans also saw him as just kind
of a bit of a wonky character that was
intriguing and a little eccentric
because he was one of the only holdovers
who remembered the way things were that
he existed before the events of crisis
on infinite earth and when that crisis
event ended and you had new earth and
most of the heroes didn't remember
anything before that he did and so it
was always just a part of his character
he's like i always remember the way that
things were supposed to be a lot of it
seems to be the result of him using
medusa's mask the ability to manipulate
the emotional state of other individuals
to achieve a particular goal but that's
what's going on here with barry that
barry is basically being tricked by
illusions using medusa's mask into
thinking he's running alongside jay
garrick and he has to protect the
multiverse and to do that he has to keep
running faster when the reality here is
he's basically hooked up to a machine
that's not that far removed from the one
that was used during the original crisis
event to power the efforts of the
anti-monitor and in turn is just running
faster and faster and faster but all of
this is being done by the manipulations
of psychopirate and so that's what's so
crazy here is he does not actually know
what he's doing he has no clue what's
happening now in terms of how this will
affect things on a larger scale we'll of
course find out about that as time goes
on but what you end up doing here is
basically transitioning over to uh to
alan scott or back to alan scott and to
obsidian where they basically end up
locating what was in effect a place
called command d now of course this is
located in bloodhaven but the idea here
is that after the events of essentially
the dark crisis story right so batman
who laughs and all that kind of stuff
perpetua and everything after all that
had been done the world had become aware
of the multiverse the threats in the
multiverse that much like we talked
about before that the deo's entire basis
shifted away from being a group that was
in effect amanda waller of the suicide
squad's kind of intelligence arm keeping
her abreast of all the different
super-powered beings that exist out
there monitoring them seeing which ones
could presumably be used for the suicide
squad as well as which ones are credible
threats and now they focus on the
multiverse the various threats that
exist out there from across all of
creation so for those of you guys who
are coming from marvel comics think of
the current function of the deo as
basically armor right the alternate
reality monitoring and operations what
is it response division or whatever it
is but basically that right the group of
marvel comics that monitors the
multiverse that's what the deo does now
now of course their charter is a little
more direct than armors is and in fact
we'll actually see how that plays out
but the thing about this is that as they
get in there they kind of sense these
little indications of power that belong
to jake right kind of picking up on what
are essentially breadcrumbs little bits
of her now of course during this time
they end up coming across bones right
the guy who's running the deo and the
question being what does this guy have
to do with it right are they responsible
for the kidnapping of jade and so once
they basically follow this guy through
they ultimately get to this giant ship
that he has they're basically met by
extract now force extract is a character
that is a little bit ambiguous here in
terms of how she's being told in the
story we don't necessarily know her full
backstory we simply just know that she's
the agent that's sent in by bones to
basically retrieve people or to save
people or whatever it is but the ability
to teleport in and teleport out hence
the name extract and so as a result of
that she basically jumps in and then
essentially sets or really you know
shows alan scott in obsidian they had an
effect walked into a trap now they do
what they can to hold off against these
guys but of course chase ends up
stepping in and she basically
incapacitates the both of them and
they're really kind of out for the count
right they're basically taken now this
is when things get really really wild
and this is where this entire story the
the entire nature of infinite frontier
dark crisis this is all a reboot so for
those of you guys who have been looking
at the nature of or at least looking at
the reviews or people are saying this
entire crisis event is really no
different than zero hour or any of that
stuff they're really accurate here right
and it's one of those things where
people are in a lot of ways kind of
getting a little tired of it where you
got the whole perpetua thing the
restoration of the multiverse then
that's just one part of the story now
this is the other part of the story kind
of picking up after that and in a lot of
ways it really is the kind of grand
reshuffling of dc what's so ironic
though is that for those of you guys who
have been reading comics for any real
measure of time you'll probably agree
with me in saying that what dc is doing
here is really no different than what
marvel did in the early 2000s right with
like spider-man one more day house of
m's civil war thor ragnarok all that
stuff right running all the way up to
the heroic age right so like messiah
complex messiah war all those things
it's really no different here right it
really is in a lot of ways the exact
same thing that marvel was doing that if
the events of perpetua and that whole
crisis event was basically them just
quote unquote rebooting the multiverse
what this is doing is showing us what
that reboot looks like now right so
think of it like a as a kind of extended
epilogue or a part two of dc reboots yet
again right that's really kind of kind
of what this is but what this does is it
switches over to roy harper where he's
basically on this ship right and what's
crazy is he's met by a guy named agent
hammond that's when hammond's like we're
with the deo right and the response of
roy is okay so like you keep an eye out
for aliens right he's like well aliens
were our task before everything popped
off but after everything this happened
with like the multiverse and all that
kind of stuff we were reinstated with a
whole new mission so literally to
protect earth zero's interest from a
different kind of invader and so we're
void asked so basically you keep your
eye out for anyone trying to like crash
into our world or conquer our world or
invade our world the response of hammond
is exactly right that's exactly what we
do or somebody who just essentially came
back from the dead and that's when they
incapacitate roy harper and that's when
hammond says like we weren't really sure
if this was going to work because you
were a black lantern but at the end of
the day i do have some familiarity with
lantern rings and that's when we find
out this guy hammond is actually hector
hammond now the initial response that i
had here was okay so how did this happen
because the last time we saw hector
hammond he was a little guy with a giant
head how did this change and this is one
of those reboot elements where what we
end up finding out is that when the
multiverse was returned to normal hector
hammond was reset back to zero he
literally says that right like when
reality returned i was quote unquote
reset to factory settings so to speak so
he's back to the way he was before
everything went nuts with his experiment
so he's still every bit the villain that
he always was before but what he says or
what he does is he transitions roy to a
place called the bleed now for those of
you guys who don't know about that and i
think we talked about it a little bit in
some of the videos that we did before
the bleed is basically the place between
universes jonathan hickman borrowed
heavily off of this when he was doing
the whole avengers and new avengers
story and you had the space between
universes so that's it's really the
exact same concept just borrowed from dc
comics this is when things get really
really intriguing because what hector
says is this is called the bleed right
the space between worlds in the
multiverse and he says when we heard
that you were alive we had to know how
and so we sent extract to collect you
she thought you were just a simple
archer imagine our surprise when you had
that ring and he says that black ring
you have on your hand i'm not even sure
it's from our multiverse but it shows
you why and when roy responds i don't
know the response of hector is we didn't
expect you to or i didn't expect you to
but a deal has been made for you and
that ring roy thomas and then ultimately
we never find out what it is because a
massive crash happens now the big
takeaway from this is the statement from
hector hammond that we're not even sure
if that ring is from our multiverse
that's one of the things to understand
here about this story it's a massive
expansion to the dc landscape that is
really being altered right that's really
changing everything we've known up to
this point and i don't mean to do the
whole marvel comics you know the
obligatory and it's going to change
everything forever you know you know i
don't mean to to come off like that but
it's simply one of these things where it
is a pretty big change that happens in
this story the entire events of dark
crisis and so what ends up happening is
in this momentary distraction based on
whatever it was that had happened to the
ship of hector hammond they basically
have roy who ends up conjuring
constructs turns into a bit of a kind of
zombified version of himself but it does
allow him to basically overcome hector
by literally creating a construct of hal
jordan
[Laughter]
to attack hector hammond which is a nice
little touch but somebody somewhere just
kind of says okay so like they must have
found some zombie world in the
multiverse and you know what that means
aim for the heck and we end up finding
out this statement is being made by jade
power girl along with uh adam smasher
and like danger and like it's it's cool
and it looks like wild cat but wildcat
as far as i'm aware is a guy so it's
kind of weird to see like a chick wild
cat maybe i'm missing something i'm not
entirely sure but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this to an end
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace